okay now the Handy's ratio is rates and
time which is why you can see there are
number one so many ratios in here but we
usually call ratios by a different name
starts with an F fractions right like
these guys okay ratios fractions really
the same kind of thing
lots of greats as well but rates are all
in units right that's why you get
centimeters in here in time as well
many rates are something per our point
per minute or per second right which is
why we include all these ideas together
right so let's see how are we gonna go
well I can you start me off with
question want me to mean is how many
centimeters 200 fantastic so we gotta
multiply by 100 you might remember that
on that decimal metric sorry diagram
that shows me how to convert between
kilometers meters centimeters
millimeters okay so we multiply by
hundred no big deal
greatest common divisor which is GCD for
short that's the biggest number that's a
factor of both of those Brendan you're
taking then six okay six divides into 12
twice it divides into 18 three times is
there a bigger one
hmm it's easy to check when you look at
the smaller number smaller numbers tend
to have less factors that are always but
they tend to write so what's a bigger
factor than six that fits into 12 what's
the next factor after six it's it's 12
isn't it right like you can't get any
other factors and 12 truly doesn't
divide it in this so we already have the
biggest one that makes it 7 over 10
what's our equivalent fraction yep 21
over 13 how do we get that how do we go
Carsten yo
yeah yeah good good so the whole idea of
the crew fractions is if you do the same
thing to the denominator as the
numerator the fractions will stay the
same so long as you're multiplying or
dividing right like for instance a
common error is to answer 27 that's a
very common error to make how did I make
that error I added instead of
multiplying right so 10 you add 20 to
get to 30 so how that I add 20 to get to
37 why is that a problem
yeah that's exactly right like you can
check you can actually control a diagram
if you like 27 out of 30 is quite a lot
more than seven out of 10 right and not
to mention Network fractions right like
this sum this fraction side
what's an abbreviation for what
operation is it it's yeah it's division
right so it's division it's all about
dividing and multiplying this is not an
adding subtracting piates it's a
multiply divide thing so that's why 20
what is exactly right okay who must have
got the next question all right well you
got to go Morgan you I knew a suggestion
six
okay now lowest common multiple right in
other words that's the smallest number
that has both of these as a factor how
would you get 6 how did you get that out
yeah you don't three okay now 2 times 3
is a nice quick way to get 6 however
just be careful off on the side where
you put you're working over on the right
hand side here I want you to write down
this for me okay now just for
illustration right because it shows you
some methods are okay but they're not
always perfect I could get a multiple of
10 or 15 by multiplying them just like I
do here okay but I can tell you right
now it's not going to be the lowest
common one not by a long shot
10 times 15 of course is 150 which is a
multiple of 10 and it is a multiple of
15 but someone can tell me a smaller
bottle for surely that will go into both
of those right me enjoying it birdie
thank you very good
now thirties much better how do we have
30 cuz much much more yeah
it's because you
10 2013 15 good good
so lowest common multiple common means
it's a multiple of this one and it's a
multiple of this one so you can write
down your multiples of 20 you can go to
10 as it was just suggested 10 20 30
into your multiples of 15 and a suti the
second one
oh it's common tux on lowest common
multiple you carried that so just just
watch out now we question before we move
on to number five why didn't always
common multiples appear in a question a
set of questions about ratios what's
that about
why are Lois called multiples useful to
ratios and fractions yeah five would be
a divisor oh right so you answering
other questions yeah Adam don't give it
a thought yeah that's exactly right
it's about linking that getting
commonality between something like this
example let's take this number he gave
you this way and this okay now if I just
gave you that question forget about all
of this for a second right what would
you have to do to this in order to put
them together someone hasn't said
anything yet I need a common denominator
right did you hear that word common
common denominator you want the lowest
common multiple because that'll be the
smallest number of course you could do
it over 150 but why why huge numbers
why not small numbers okay all right 289
445 who's got the someone who has
anything yet he's got a common sorry the
equivalent fraction Oh me oh no this
anything uh yeah no need to fine now
what did we do to get that because
exactly right yeah okay I am um the
number I what is nine nine is the grant
greatest common divisor on both of these
you see how they don't fit yeah
what did i do i divided two no right um
so therefore 18 describe divisor okay um
two fifths of 20 you can all tell me
what to fit this when your right is
right it's
because 115 last bit on time these are
actually both easy to convert to 24-hour
right all we have to wrap for an a and
time is 0
don't forget the 0 7 1 5 let's just
hypothetically just like I did before
what if there was 7:15 p.m. how would
that change this morning
very good because the difference between
AM and PM is 12 hours right because the
clock has 12 hours on the face so yeah
another talk last one for 10:00 in the
morning when the afternoon and it's the
morning walk nailed it
okay fantastic